[Music]
now I didn't know you were a drummer you
were a drummer you're a musician that's
right
I play the drums it's probably hard to
picture but it happens but I was in a
yeah I wanted to tell you that I was in
a high school band we had a show where
we were playing a dinner dance for it
was for mentally challenged children and
adults and their parents and caretakers
and stuff and what that got you no no I
you tell your story all right fine it
reminded me it was it's about you it's
not about me it's about no I so we're
playing down on the corner the Creedence
Clearwater song yet on the corner sure
there's a break it down part of that
song you guys know what I mean yeah I'm
gonna break that and our bassist was
singing lead vocals he grabs his bass
with this hand and he grabbed the mic
with this hand and he became a part of
an electrical current like something
wasn't grounded so he was well he was
being electrocuted and he couldn't let
go of the mic or the bass and his mouth
was right up to the mic and he just goes
oh oh
[Laughter]
the audience is 100% mentally challenged
today like Goku one day that's I did
stand up in front of them once and
everything I said they went ooh but I
didn't know the situation right up until
that point they had been having a good
time but then it was just total chaos
right I would think so and you can't
know did you try and work did you try
and play on after that or after the
basis of died yeah the basis usually
means it's time to go it's time to go
yeah no the our guitars just turned off
the amp that's all you have to do in
that situation if you're wondering but
no we did not we did not play on for
some medical attention yeah let's talk
about your show review this is a show
which is hilarious where your character
reviews life right instead of reviewing
movies or books or anything like that
this character reviews life experiences
that are submitted to him by his
audience and he'll do whatever anybody
asked him to do no matter what it is
because he believes it's truly for the
good of humanity he's an idiot right
yeah we have a clip here what's
happening in this clip I believe the
clip we're about to show is that he has
been asked to review what is it like to
sleep with the celebrity and he has
targeted Ashley Tisdale is his this is
targeted celebrity and so he goes to a
celebrity auction that she's involved
with where they're auctioning off a date
with Ashley Tisdale and he has to win
this because this is his best shot to
sleep with a celeb and I believe our own
Andy Richter is part of this madness
yeah he's okay and lied let's let's take
a look at this clip from review 15
$15,000 15 15 $15,000 of the doting
father of that
lucky young lady back there now to our
20 $20,000 $20,000 and able to last
rather get back to supper fare over
there 25 $25,000 we've got ourselves a
real bidding war going on here do I hear
30 have any thousand dollars so many
thousand $70,000 okay going twice
that's it right
[Applause]
[Music]
you're wrong about your time no I love
Andy so I have extended this segment Wow
here's so far